[Music]
foreign
you know I look at our net what I call
negative ego States and there's a whole
array array of them anger resentment
fear Envy victimhood Etc there's about
20 what I call negative ego states that
plague people
either they plague them interpersonally
or they're inner aggressive anxiety fear
shame worthlessness Etc so they attack
the self
even the self-attacking ones are very
disruptive of interpersonal
relationships
so very early on
I really wanted to understand regulating
the inner life
and I also learned early on without
recourse to traditional talking
psychotherapy
for some people it works great to talk
about your past for other people it
locks in those neurological patterns so
I've decided take on negative ego States
as something to take on in Jewish
spiritual psychology we call the
yesahara destructive like a destructive
shape within you
so because of my interest in what we
call Shadow work which means like the
jungian idea that everybody has a shadow
these Shadows get manifested in these
negative ego States I teach a practice
where you want to be aware of them
watch how they operate and go after them
so it's a it's a spiritual Warrior kind
of a thing so I don't I don't want to
wait until a symptom hits
and takes over a part of my day or or
damages the relationship
I recommend going after them proactively
with the higher self working on
disruptive ego can you give us an
example well let's say anger
um number one I think a big part of
angry people are it's genetic and
personality so people just run hot other
people run defensive let's say we're
just going to take these two archetypes
angry people are super sensitive to
being let down
to being disappointed
um to not having not being able to
control others control situations trying
to manage outcomes
dominate other people
and when that happens they feel like at
a primal level a threat
and they need to take care of the threat
so one way is anger
and even Without Anger there's crit I
call it the four C's criticizing
complaining
condemning insulting labeling blaming
accusing and then escalating contract so
when I first began counseling people I
thought
whatever this thing is you know because
it it manifests in anger or
criticizing complaining and condemning
Etc
it's not what the other person did
because it's almost all disproportionate
and secondly if it is about what they
did that's a guaranteed wrong way to
change people
unless you have overwhelming coercive
power
most people don't transform under insult
in fact which oftentimes get is Defiance
and pushback
so let's say a person says well you
wouldn't believe what my spouse said you
will believe what my teenager did I said
I believe everything I'm going to ask
you rationally speaking
is criticizing your spouse gonna make
them more likely to meet their your
needs I will venture to Guess that he
criticized spouse will meet fewer of
your needs
then a spouse who's not criticized so
what do you do ah it's not the spouse
it's the ego state right there's a
there's a Shadow Force in there that
wants to unleash on other people okay so
you got to fight the anger what you
don't do is uh sorry is um well my
father my mother it might work with some
people but you have to proactively go to
what I call the higher self
go down and work with the ego state so
what I found is disruptive ego States
all have a look they begin as a Feeling
but it sum up all feelings have thoughts
okay
so when I say
explain to me the thought behind
criticism assuming there is one well I
have to correct them
that's a rational thought I have to
correct them it's not true but at least
it makes sense in the English language
they can't get away with this there's
always some thought there I say okay
well let's examine those thoughts okay
now this is an interesting thing you go
to a higher self where we have
the ability to observe
the ability to be objective about our
inner lives the ability to be rational
to aim at the truth so everything in
here is activated and brought to bear
against the ego state of anger and the
ego state of anger just Withers it
cannot stand this investigation
so let's say okay you're right it will
not make things better
it's making everything worse my anger
makes everything worse it makes me sick
it makes them sick and it and it it's so
disruptive I say great so there's no
reason
so tell me
why the anger gets out
they said I don't know does that sound
reasonable but people in the end will
say I don't know you're right it's
thoughtless it's destructive I don't
know I said no you need to listen very
carefully
because you haven't decided
you haven't decided to stop being
destructive
I said I I guarantee this they say well
you wouldn't believe what they say I
said I lived in San Diego for three
months where these four guys insulted me
every single day and I never got mad
once about what what were they insulting
you
uh well
that I didn't hold my rifle correctly
but it run fast enough it was okay yeah
these four guys three months straight
beating me insulting me smacking me
around I never said listen here sir
right I need to how dare you how dare
you never occurred to me yeah so anger
is not a response to what someone does
right this response to what you think
you can do right
so they said okay how do I stop so this
is where I talk about the wall of virtue
you need to make a decision
it's a decision like when anger comes
and hits a wall I'm saying no to my
anger
and there are people that can say you're
100 right
I'll train myself on my own time
this is what I call my wisdom practice I
will go down inside I will discover my
negative ego States I will reason with
them I will discover what the righteous
path is what the honor what the what the
honor code is
and whenever I have an urge to break the
honor code I will have a wall of virtue
that says no
and first thing it does it hits the wall
of virtue doesn't matter what I feel
doesn't matter what I think I have an
honor code
okay then people say well isn't that
repression I said it's called a
restraint
now you have to work through the impulse
to break your honor code
but I have an honor code first I'm not
going to say well I haven't thought it
through so I don't have to live by an
honor code but that doesn't work for me
go find another teacher because if a
person I don't mind if people fail the
honor code
they have to commit to the honor code
so as a person commits the honor code I
say I can help you
because you're in a fight for what kind
of person you want to be an honorable
person
or a person who lacks The Strain lacks
honor lacks Integrity I mean Integrity
meaning you live up to your values so
there's that the wall of virtue which
means my disruptive ego States hit a
wall of virtual wall of Honor I've made
an a prior commitment that it doesn't
get expressed
it pops down into the place where I work
it through and over time
I disable
the angry habit
and you replace it with another habit
empathy thoughtfulness
listening working through which means
you can't just diminish the power of one
ego State you have to increase the power
of a positive ecostate now I want to say
to you guys this does take time sure it
takes a lot of training it's like
martial arts sure you gotta get on the
mat
every day train train train
and then one day people do it what's
that can young people do it yeah
absolutely they're the best I mean I was
teaching this to my bar mitzvah kids
they were all over it because one of the
things we were talking about that you
know it's like that that Paul Simon song
like I look back on all the crap I
learned in high school and and you know
my kids are sitting upstairs like
learning cursive you know but but they
learn nothing about like emotional
management about any of these things
that
Far and Away would have way more life
benefit have you ever thought about like
I mean it feels like this is something
that like in a high school curriculum of
some kind would be immensely valuable
but there's nothing like that out there
so I taught classical parenting the soul
of the child right I specifically teach
parents not to raise their children for
external outcomes
but parenting the soul of the child
what I say in this class is the greatest
gift you can give your child is the gift
of insight
who am I what's going inside of me
and then the gift of virtue how to match
what's going on inside of me and the
gift of working through
so what I say to parents make this part
of your family culture when your family
sits down to dinner
when your family goes on vacation
whatever your family's going to talk
about talk about wisdom and virtue and
inner life make it a fact
[Music]
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we're
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I going to have my
son Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
the warrior blend which is a little bit
lighter if you're trying to cut and uh I
believe in it I believe in that some
Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones for 15 off I appreciate y'all
foreign
[Music]